[Music]
we have to know where we come from to
know where we are going unfortunately
many of us were not listening to the
teacher in class but history doesn't
have to be boring in fact it is much
more interesting when you find out
things teachers didn't want you to know
have you ever seen an elephant
waterskiing make sure you watch this
video to see more impressive historical
pictures like this if this is your first
time visiting our channel make sure you
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up here are 10
pictures they won't show you in history
books the bathing suit inspector
nowadays bikinis barely cover what has
to be covered it allows us to swim
freely and make sure we don't have too
many tan lines went sunbathing on the
beach but decades ago bathing suits were
much more different than 1800s we
couldn't even see women's legs and the
frock was buttoned up to the neck then
in the 1900s it looked more like women
were wearing a dress made from heavy
flannel or wool fabric it was not until
the 1950s that the bikini was
popularized with icons like Marilyn
Monroe and Brigitte Bardot the revealing
bathing suit became less shocking and
more accepted but let's go back to 1922
form-fitting swimsuits were becoming
more popular so directors of public
beaches implemented strict dress codes
to make sure the swimsuits were
appropriate someone issued an order that
bathing suits at the Washington beach
could not be over six inches above the
knee this is why bathing beach cops like
this one in the picture use a tape
measure to determine if the swimsuit was
appropriate there was also a dress code
for men but censors were less severe
with them if women didn't respect the
code it was punishable by fines or even
imprisonment many of us would already be
behind bars if the same rule existed
today war is hell we think of American
soldiers as heroes and we are right to
see them this way these courageous men
and women risk their lives for their
country they are part of the reason why
we are still here today but what we
don't talk about is what really happened
during the war it
not only a story of conflict between two
countries but also many personal stories
during the war in Vietnam a lot of
soldiers wrote messages on their helmet
to tell about how they were feeling some
soldiers wrote about their faith in God
others talked about their fatal fate
many of them just wanted peace it was a
way for them to be more than another
body lying on the ground but one of
these men who served in Vietnam
captivated us with an innocent smile on
his face even though you could read war
is hell on his helmet photo journalist
Horst Voss captured this picture of the
Unknown Soldier later identified as
Larry Wayne Chaffin war as hell was not
only something to be taken literally but
also a quote from William Tecumseh
Sherman the general said in 1864 that
soldiers should not hope or desire to
use the skills they acquire in the
academy they didn't know the horrible
aspects of war war is hell iron lungs
for polio victims once you see this
picture you won't be afraid of needles
anymore but instead of iron lungs before
vaccination more than 15,000 Americans
contracted a paralyzing form of polio
each year a highly infectious disease
they weren't even able to breathe when
muscles in their chest stopped working
fortunately physicians found a way to
help the polio victims the tank
respirator better known as the iron lung
it cost $1,500 the price of an average
house at the time but it was certainly
necessary the machine was breathing for
them changing the pressure so the lungs
could expand and contract unfortunately
even though they had the chance to stay
alive patients could barely do anything
all they could do was looking at a
mirror reflecting the room behind them
nurses would even help them smoke
Hospital policies on smoking were really
different in the 1940s moreover those
affected by the disease didn't only
spend days in these machines they were
there for months years and sometimes
their entire life this girl spent 60
years in the iron lung they were
probably the most patient people in the
world but no matter what the invention
saved thousands of lives
the polio victims looked happy in these
pictures and we hope
they will keep smiling the only known
meteorite victim everyone heard about
the first man who went into space but no
one talks about the first time space
decided to knock on a woman's door in
1954 in Alabama and Hodges was struck by
a meteorite when she was napping on her
couch a black rock the size of a
softball came out of nowhere and
suddenly hit her on the thigh leaving an
enormous bruise she first assumed that
children were responsible for this but
little did she know she had become the
first human to be struck by a meteorite
meteorites usually fall in the sea or in
vast remote places according to
astronomer Michael Reynolds you have
more chance of getting hit by a tornado
a bolt of lightning and a hurricane at
the same time this kind of event was
really rare in human history but what
happened to the strange black rock
falling from the sky the police
confiscated it and turned it over to the
United States Air Force they confirmed
it was a meteorite but didn't know what
to do with it the public wanted an to
have the rock but someone else was
interested in it the landlady she sued
them and claimed that the rock was hers
because it fell on her property and in
her husband finally bought the meteorite
for $500 and donated it to the Natural
History Museum inflatable tanks why use
fake inflatable tanks during a very real
war as long as the enemy think it is
real it is a great way to defend
yourself an elite forces specialty was
tactical deception they were not
selected for their strengths but their
acting skills and their creativity and
they had one big mission to fool Hitler
dummy versions of the tanks were
constructed from a wooden framework and
inflatable tubes covered with rubberized
canvas they didn't work but wheels were
concealed underneath so soldiers could
easily move them around there were not
only hundreds of inflatable tanks but
also cannons trucks and even airplanes
during World War two allied forces use
them as a way to look like they were
prepared to fight with the illusion 1000
men from the ghost army could look like
they were 30,000 men their goal was to
discourage the enemy by making a site
seemed like he was heavily defended by
thinking that the Allies had more tanks
than they did
were quickly confused this is how they
were able to protect their weakest spot
the tactic was also a good way to draw
enemy troops away from real American
units it was part of the reason why the
Allies from the ghost army were able to
win the war you don't have to be the
most powerful to succeed as long as you
are the smartest for children for sale
when we see a picture of a pregnant
mother trying to sell her four children
we all hope that this photo was staged
why would anyone want to leave their
children but unfortunately this story
was true in Chicago in August 1948
Lucille Shelley foo and her husband did
have to sell their kids they faced
eviction from their apartment had no
place to turn and had no job this was
when they knew that they couldn't take
care of their family anymore the
children were all adopted two years
after this photo was taken and sent in
different directions one of them rayann
later claimed she was sold for only $2
so her mother could have bingo money
the Shila foo were too poor to take care
of their kids but they were not adopted
by better families most of them lived a
really difficult life Rayanne met her
birth mother later when she was 21 years
old and remembers as she didn't have any
remorse or regret in that time the
decision was nothing but survival
Lucille was thinking about her children
and wanted them to have a better life
and there was no other way to find help
fortunately there is a happy ending to
this story
years later sisters Rayanne and Lana
contacted each other via social media
they finally reunited in 2013 and Ryan
said that it was one of the happiest
days of her life the female bootleggers
you remember the prohibition in the
1920s in the United States no one had
the right to produce import transport or
sell alcohol but as you can guess many
people didn't care about that and
decided to drink alcohol anyway it was
not an easy thing to do for men because
they were quickly arrested by the police
this is why they decided to recruit into
their ranks different people who could
help them women in many states police
officers didn't have the right to search
a woman she could hide flasks and even
cases under her clothes and if they
tried to touch her she threatened to sue
them if women didn't want to work as
bootleggers just being next to men was
enough
self-respecting federal agent wanted to
hold up a vehicle if a woman was sitting
in it women bootleggers were so good
they could earn about $30,000 a year
which is now worth about four hundred
thousand even when female bootleggers
were arrested juries were nicer to them
because they didn't want mothers to stay
away from their children for too long
a woman was simply sentenced to attend
church every Sunday for two years but
even when women weren't there men find
ways to transport alcohol without being
followed by the police there were
special shoes to disguise their
footprints and make them believe a cow
had just walked by the Mickey Mouse gas
mask when we think of Mickey Mouse we
imagine a fun little Mouse the cartoon
character has been Disney's mascot since
his creation in 1928 and children can't
stop loving him but what you might not
know is that Mickey Mouse was also used
for something more serious a gas mask
for children in 1942 during World War 2
the government feared harmful gas from
the Germans millions of gas masks were
distributed to men women and children in
the United States and Europe but Disney
wanted the children to feel better
during the sad period of time many of
them didn't want to wear a respirator
and anyway they were too big for them
this is why Disney helped design Mickey
Mouse gas masks for children aged 18
months to four years old it had the
characters nose and ears and even a
picture of him on the gas filter many
different designs were created to help
children all around the world survive in
the war it was supposed to be worn as a
kind of game to take away their fears
during this scary moment of history
unfortunately seeing this was a little
scary for parents but no matter what as
long as the kids were happy and safe the
Mickey Mouse gas mask was a great idea
Queeny the skiing elephant now there is
one great reason to go back to the 1950s
meet Queenie the only elephant who can
ski on water amazing isn't it the animal
was only six months old when she was
bought in a pet store in New York in
1953 she was brought to a Florida theme
park where animals performed 15 times a
day her owner Liz Dane began training
her years after so she could ski on
water
Queenie also learned how to stand on
feet and follow the orders of Liz for 15
years in the 1950s in the 1960s the
crowd-pleasing elephant was really
popular and performed three or four
times a day
Queenie traveled across the country to
show off her impressive skills however
some people didn't agree with this kind
of lifestyle they believe that Queenie
never chose this life of servitude so it
wasn't right to use her for performances
but her owner Liz Dane claims she never
forced the elephant to do anything she
loved to water-ski
Queenie was a member of Danes family and
received all the love she could get the
elephant retired in 2003 at age 51
because of chronic health problems the
wild adventure theme park offered her a
great place to live out the rest of her
life
Queenie is still making everyone smile
but this time she performs in heaven
since 2011 a woman running the Boston
Marathon we know that women can be just
as strong as men but many people didn't
believe it in Boston in 1967 no one
thought a woman could run more than 26
miles at a time so Katharine Switzer had
to prove them that she could she got the
rulebook of the Boston Marathon and saw
that there was nothing about women being
forbidden this is why the runner decided
to sign up before the event at the race
Katherine didn't try to hide her
identity she was proud to be the first
woman to participate in the Boston
Marathon unfortunately some people
weren't too happy about it when she was
running a man grabbed her by the shirt
and tried to force her to get out of the
marathon he even tried to rip off her
bib numbers her boyfriend Tom got rid of
this man but got in trouble because of
that Katherine was getting really scared
and emotional but she still managed to
finish the marathon when asked why she
was doing that she answered that she
simply wanted to run but after this
event she knew it meant more than that
it was a way to prove what women can do
Katharine Switzer didn't win the race
but she did win something more important
she gave women the opportunity to be
strong and powerful athletes just like
she was which pictures would you like to
see in your history books don't be shy
and tell us in the comments down below
and for more interesting facts don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel
thanks for watching bye bye
[Music]